what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent planet eva
liva marinova
looking like a sheep don't forget well
while she's trying to get rich for us
just trying to get our lunch money right
and also block five is now a sponsor
block five block five block five dot com
block five dot com slash pomp block five
dot com slash pomp go
check them out you can earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an
interest-bearing account
it's a no-brainer 8.6
apy is unheard of in the traditional
world but not at block five they got you
get money get paid i'm an investor i sit
on the board
it is point also percent ap wide and
spring account go sign up block buy dot
com
slash pop i'm the best ad reader in the
world that's all off the
dome let's go let me rant today i know
you all liked the rant yesterday but i
got one for you today
go ahead the first topic
there is an op-ed in the new york times
called stop doing that
called america's money men could save us
they're stuck in the 70s
isn't there a 50 cent song that's like
money money men
money men many men no wish death upon me
i thought it was money no i'm positive i
used to listen to that [ __ ] while we
were driving
in the streets of iraq facts yeah y'all
don't know that
okay
guys what is happening today so the
money men tell us because you wrote
about in your newsletter this morning
this is mislabeled this shouldn't be
labeled an op-ed this should be labeled
outright propaganda this is garbage what
does it say first explain what it says
there's a person who wrote in the new
york times
that we should they're advocating for
socialism that's basically what they're
doing they're saying that the federal
reserve can save the economy
and the federal reserve should start
giving out low-cost loans
that turn into grants for businesses
they're saying that the federal reserve
should start sending money directly to
people
in a universal basic income type
structure and they're also saying that
congress should change the federal
reserve act of 1913 and give the federal
reserve more power
this is an outright assault on
capitalism
and it's being passed off as an op-ed in
the new york times
this is absurd and if people don't say
something
then they're just as guilty as the as
the people who have originated these
ideas
you cannot give free money to companies
give free money to people and give the
federal reserve more power
and expect to have an economy that is
sustainable
that continues to have capitalistic
ideals and
also leads to innovation growth and
production what they are trying to do
is implement socialism that's what this
is it is
outright socialism you cannot have
free money just dropped to everybody
this is nonsense
and then on top of it it's like oh by
the way congress can't save us
capitalism can't save us we'll just give
the federal reserve more powers
have you seen what these people want to
do
the world bank chief economy
is that the next topic yes okay all i'm
gonna say about this
is we can just pause right there there
is socialism
being advocated for in the new york
times is being passed off as
oh the federal reserve can save us the
federal reserve and
inflation and the monetary stimulus and
the constant intervention in markets
is the number one cause the number one
cause of wealth inequality in the
america this is the beauty of freedom of
speech
this woman who is a new york times
contributor can write her opinion
and our lovely friend over here can
wildly disagree with it this is healthy
debate this is good for
america of course okay but i just want
everyone to know there's
fools out there there are fools out
there
and these fools are literally advocating
for socialism
if you want to live in a socialist
country go somewhere else that's not
what this country was built on
that's not what made us the greatest
economy in the world that's not what led
to technology and innovation
that is not what leads to progress
this is dumb and we do not need people
to depend on the government the
government ain't coming to save you
the federal reserve ain't coming to save
you educate yourself
make your own decisions and make sure
that you're in a position so that
you will be successful it's on you it's
about personal responsibility it's not
on government responsibility or federal
reserve responsibility
it's personal responsibility if you want
to succeed educate yourself and do the
things necessary
to succeed don't wait around for a bunch
of rich people
to say oh i'm just gonna drop money on
you and
oh please give me some money this is
garbage it's stupid
dangerous inaccurate bad ideas
being propagated as op-eds and it's not
that
it's propaganda okay you can move on
top world bank economist says financial
crisis could emerge from pandemic
so world bank chief economist carmen
reinhardt said the coronavius pandemic
concerning into a major
economic crisis and warned of the
possibility of a financial crisis
emerging
this does this did not start as a
financial crisis
but it is morphing into a major economic
crisis with very serious financial
consequences
there's a long road ahead
carmen reinhardt is a gangster this is
what you wrote about it
in the most positive way right she along
with kenneth rogoff
uh who both at harvard wrote a book uh
what's the name
i forget the name of the title is
different eight centuries of financial
folly oh folly they wrote this in 2009
and they are widely widely regarded as
experts in everything from currencies
inflation bank runs all this kind of
stuff
she was hired as the chief economist at
the world bank earlier this year
and she is now coming out and the words
that she's using are very important
she's saying this is war in terms of
central banks buying up bonds to keep
yields low
and they're all competing with each
other as to who can buy more
she is a staunch critic of debt
yet she is now saying we gotta win the
war
and we'll worry about how to pay it
later she knows what she's talking about
but that's what's happening
is they are loading up countries with
debt and saying we'll figure it out
later we'll figure it out later
well news flash they only got two
options to
pay off the debt you either one don't
and you default
or two you continue to manipulate
and devalue a currency so that you can
use cheap capital
to pay off the debt later either way the
bottom 50
get hurt and it's basically kicking the
can down the road yes
it mitigates the short-term pain and it
makes the long-term
unsustainable and so she recognizes that
but she's saying
hey i don't like all the debt but i want
to mitigate the short-term pain and
instead we're going to give up the
long-term sustainability there's a long
road ahead she thinks it's going to take
five years to recover
from this and she's warning of an even
worse financial crisis
coming off of this the financial crisis
if it happens won't be caused by kovid
it'll be caused by the federal reserve
stepping in and other central banks
around the world
manipulating markets intervening and
then their response to covet
will actually be the cause but doesn't
this kind of contradict what you just
said in the last rant where it was like
you know you're saying like the house is
on fire let's give
people money now even though it's bad
for the long term
i don't agree oh but you just said no
that's what that's her argument
her argument is hey fight the war now
pay for it later like we'll figure out
later i'm arguing
look by the way it's socialism whether
you give it to the people or you give it
to wall street
all this quantitative easing that's just
socialism for rich people
right uh my friend travis cling always
says uh quantitative easing
is universal basic income for the
wealthy it's all the same
right i've been against all this
nonsense don't bail out the airlines
don't print money don't do any of this
nonsense i don't care who you're saying
you're going to give it to
but what's even worse is not only did
they do it but then they gave all the
money to the rich people they bailed out
wall street right they bailed out all
the companies
and now what we're seeing is now they're
advocating oh maybe we should give money
to people too
we shouldn't do any of it and we should
allow the free market to rain
the reason why people don't want the
free market to rain is because that
means
well of course there's gonna be pain but
there's pain right now so they stepped
in they did all this stuff and actually
made it worse for people who aren't
wealthy
think about that the federal reserve
made it worse for people who aren't
wealthy
and it's only gonna get worse inflation
right now the unofficial numbers
inflation is probably somewhere between
six to ten percent and the people in the
lowest socioeconomic classes
they actually experience inflation at a
higher rate than people in the highest
second
socioeconomic classes and if they
continue to print money like the way
they're doing it and if they continue to
intervene in markets it's only going to
get worse
and i'm calling it right now if we
continue on this path the lowest
socioeconomic classes
in america are going to experience
somewhere between 15 and 20
inflation you think people right now
feel like they can't get ahead
you think people right now are upset
they feel like they're stuck in a rat
race wait till they're experiencing six
uh 15 to 20 inflation this
is insanity and it's all because humans
are really bad
at allowing the free market to rain we
feel like we have to do something we
feel like
we don't have control if we don't do
something there's a new system
there's a way to opt out of this garbage
i opted out there's a lot more people
gonna opt out too
i'll see you all there it's just one big
commercial for bitcoin
they're running a trillion with three
four five trillion dollar marketing
campaign for bitcoin right now i hear
you
they ran the campaign i'm just pointing
it out
okay um bitcoin's up over 50 is the
highest it's best performing asset
this year i wonder why go ahead by the
way these aren't just my ideas
paul tudor jones he agrees with me he
does stone ridge they agree with me
michael sailor he grows me jack dorsey
he agrees with me
go ahead satoshi
i didn't i didn't hear my name on that
list
you with me we partners let's go what's
next oh that was kind of sweet guys
um okay madison avenue new york city's
most
high-end retail avenue
the properties there are selling uh for
decade low prices
three buildings on madison avenue's main
retail corridor
have sold for about 80 percent below
peak sales
prices since uh in 20 in 2014.
2014 was the peak sale prices and now
they're selling for 80
less yes of course well uh because the
stores are all closed no one can pay
rent a swiss
luxury retailer acris um
was a tenant at one of the retail spaces
agreed to pay 45 million for
three properties wow yeah i mean look
duh
like well it's just that's crazy it's
gonna come back
how long it's thirteen hundred thirteen
hundred thirteen hundred and fifty
dollars per square foot but it used to
be
seven seven thousand five eighty nine
yeah eighty percent down
it's gonna come back in the sense of
unless you think new york city's going
away
in terms of like no one's gonna live
here anymore there's gonna be no foot
traffic
this is a great time to buy and that's
what they're doing they're buying real
estate at the bottom of a market
my guess is that those people are going
to make out like bandits over the next
10 years because new york is going to be
back
and it's going to be fine so you're
ready i really like this story this is a
new topic
yeah all right let's go um there's a
company five minutes left
there's a company called paystack and
they can they had kind of been marketing
themselves as
stripe for africa um and it took off
like it was really really popular it was
really well
done so eventually the founders of that
company
met with the real stripe and now it came
out that the real
stripe paid over 200 million to acquire
paysac
and it's probably kind of moving into
africa
especially nigeria where there's a lot
of this payment
um digital payment stuff happening well
stripe was an investor in the company
yes right so look i watched they put out
a video yesterday about this
these two guys that started the company
i love them literally
they're awesome they are so excited and
they're just so down to earth
they're just like look the internet you
can do anything in the world like
we live in lagos nigeria we built a
company that company worked
we literally helped all these small
businesses and merchants around
uh nigeria and other countries in africa
and now stripe bought us for 200 million
dollars
biggest acquisitions oh it's probably
it's got it
it's probably one of the biggest
technology acquisitions especially by
a company that is in silicon valley of a
company that's in uh
in the continent of africa for sure i
love this story
bang bang that's what the internet's
about not that socialism garbage let's
get more capital you see what happens
when capitalism works
all right ready for so this is a going
off of yesterday's rant yep
twitter ceo jack dorsey says blocking
the new york post story
was wrong he said
that straight blocking of urls was wrong
and we updated our policy and
enforcement to fix
our goal is to attempt to add context
and now we have capabilities to do that
this is after the company faced backlash
after blocking the new york post story
on
joe biden and corruption claims i'm cool
with uh
jack because jack did the one thing that
most leaders wouldn't do
he came out and said we got it wrong i'm
cool with that i respect that
uh should they have done it no he's
saying that
right and actually i really appreciate
the nuance he provided which was hey
here was our logic
we actually don't disagree with uh the
way the rules were applied
but we need to change the rules because
in this situation we learned something
yeah and so again you can't expect
everyone to be perfect all the time
but when somebody comes out and owns a
mistake
says here's how we're going to fix it
explains why they made the mistake
and also you can tell they're trying to
get it right
yeah and i feel like i'm good compared
to zuck i feel like dorsey's
much more open and much more transparent
and like talks to people on twitter
like you know uses twitter to explain
his logic
why why is zuck so quiet lately no he
does he's just on facebook and no one's
on facebook like none of us are on
facebook
i mean like we have facebook accounts
but we don't spend as much time on
facebook as we do on twitter all right
ready
yep meat lovers hormel is that how you
pronounce it
uh hormel has created a bacon
smelling face mask that is disgusting
it's a bacon scented face mask and while
you can't buy one
you can enter a drawing for a chance to
win one how you win
um a bacon smell technology
i kind of i kind of think this is
interesting i think you just click and
you enter a drawing
can you imagine how fat i would be
though if i'm smelling bacon all the
time
okay okay i have the best stroke ever
today if you don't laugh i'm going to be
really mad at you so consider
your options ready i i
this is a good one i looked for this one
so much
why do bitcoiners want a lambo
you're already laughing why because
ferrari is owned by
fiat
get it get it the setup i thought was
going to be
awesome okay it's a funny one
come on i even actually heard it to your
people oh man yeah if i hadn't heard it
before maybe i would have laughed
but you did laugh look at look at that
smile i laughed at the setup
cause i was not expecting that good job
all right guys
that's it for lunch money for the week
sorry
i had a couple little you know things i
needed to say but glad
let me know in the comments if you
disagree should i go on a rant
no all right that's it for lunch money
we'll see you guys on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends